يبحث الملياردير الياباني يوساكو
ميزاوا عن ثمانية أفراد من الجمهور
للانضمام إليه في رحلة مدتها ستة أيام حول
القمر
، ومن المقرر أن تنطلق الرحلة في عام 2023
على متن صاروخ سبيس إكس الذي
يمكن لأي شخص التقدم إليه من
الآن وحتى 14 مارس وستكون الرحلة.
حقق الملياردير ميزاوا ثروته من خلال
بدء شركة الأزياء للتجارة الإلكترونية عبر الإنترنت
zozo town ،
وهو يقول إنه يدفع مقابل
كامل رحلة شركة Spacex ، قال إيلون ماسك ، مؤسس شركة Spacex ، إن
هذه الرحلة يمكن أن تغامر
بأكثر مما ذهب إليه أي إنسان من قبل ،
وربما أبعد من ذلك.
المسافة التي قطعتها بعثات أبولو
، ستكون أول
رحلة فضائية تجارية أول رحلة فضائية
خاصة بالبشر خارج مدار الأرض ، لذا
لم يحدث هذا من قبل
، ونتوقع أننا سنتجاوز
القمر
مايزاوا تصدرت عناوين الصحف في عام 2018 عندما
أعلن Spacex أنه سيكون
أول
عميل خاص لهم في رحلة حول
القمر في الوقت الذي قال فيه إنه سيدعو
فنانين للحضور معه لاحقًا.
يبحث عن
شريك الحياة الخاص به ليأتي في الرحلة
معه الآن ، إنه يفتح هذا
لعامة الناس
، ويقول إن هناك معيارين رئيسيين
يبحثون عنهما للاختيار ،
أحدهما هو أن المتقدمين يجب أن
يسعوا لدفع الظرف في
مجالهم  من العمل من خلال الذهاب إلى
الفضاء ، والثاني هو أنه يجب أن يكونوا
على استعداد لدعم زملائهم من أفراد الطاقم
خلال رحلتهم
الآن ، فإن المركبة الفضائية التي تمثل
الجيل التالي من المركبات الفضائية القابلة لإعادة الاستخدام من Spacex
هي ما سيتم استخدامه في هذه الرحلة ،
سيحتاج أي شخص يتقدم بطلب إلى
شهية صحية  يمثل خطرًا لأن
صاروخ المركبة الفضائية سبيس إكس لا يزال في
المراحل الأولى من التطوير
، تم اختبار النماذج الأولية فقط
حتى الآن وانتهت الرحلات التجريبية الأخيرة
بالانفجار ، يقول إيلون ماسك إنه
واثق من
أن صاروخًا آمنًا سيكون جاهزًا بحلول عام 2023.
واثق تمامًا من أننا سنصل
إلى المدار
عدة مرات قبل عام 2023
وأنه سيكون آمنًا بما يكفي
لنقل البشر
بحلول عام 2023.  قال وا إنه
خائف قليلاً لكنه أكثر فضول
سيلينا وانغ سي إن إن طوكيو